you know when you get that ambiguous
email from your boss and you start to
feel sweaty palms and that empty freaked
out sensation in your stomach welcome
back anxiety most of us think of anxiety
as a Bad Thing something to be avoided
at all costs but what if it weren't what
if you could take all of that energy
racing around your brain and your body
and transform it into something helpful
Global anxiety levels both the clinical
kind and what I call the everyday kind
have increased tremendously in recent
years and many of us are noticing this
at work we might think of anxiety as
something that we'd rather just leave on
the side of the road if we could but
anxiety is an important tool that arose
during our Evolution that we use to
avoid danger it's essential for our
survival so how come we don't even feel
vaguely protected by it it's because the
volume of our individual and Collective
anxiety levels has been turned way up
too high and too much of even a
potentially good thing like anxiety
is bad
so I would like to share two powerful
science-based tools for turning down the
volume on our anxiety and helping us get
anxiety back to its helpful protective
State and both of these tools Begin by
connecting with our bodies
tool number one is breath work it's just
simple deep breathing
slowly inhale and exhale this can be one
of the most immediate ways to calm
anxiety because deep breath directly
activates the natural de-stressing part
of our nervous systems called the
parasympathetic nervous system I
recommend a boxed breathing approach
which is inhale deeply on four counts
hold at the top for four counts exhale
deeply on four counts and hold at the
bottom for four counts you can even do
this in the middle of any anxiety
provoking conversation and no one will
even know lots of people from ancient
monks to Modern meditators have figured
this tool out and use it all the time
tool number two moving your body this
one also has immediate positive effects
on your mood state but for a different
reason every time you move your body
you're releasing a whole bunch of
beneficial neurochemicals in your brain
these neurochemicals include dopamine
serotonin noradrenaline and endorphins
mood and reward boosting neurochemicals
that work to both increase positive mood
States and decrease negative ones I like
to say that every single time you move
your body it's like giving yourself a
wonderful bubble bath of neurochemicals
for your brain
so when your boss's email comes in and
your heart starts to race what exactly
can you do
if you're in an office try taking a
short walk around the block or even to
the Supply Closet for some sticky notes
if you're working from home put on two
of your favorite songs and dance around
the living room like no one is watching
Studies have shown that all it takes is
10 minutes of walking to get those mood
boosting effects but be creative with
your movement session whether that's a
quick session of power vacuuming Allah
Mrs Doubtfire when you're stressed about
a deadline or during a set of jumping
jacks or getting off the elevator one
floor early to do a power walk up that
last flight of stairs before an
important meeting all of these
possibilities will all help your anxiety
levels come down
in fact I tested this effect on my own
NYU students first I had them take an
anxiety assessment before leading them
in a movement session that included
movements from kickbox and dance and
yoga and martial arts together with
positive spoken affirmations
then I had them retake that same anxiety
assessment again
what happened after our movement session
their anxiety scores had decreased to
normal levels now that's powerful real
world example that you can use in your
life today so make sure to incorporate
these bursts of activity in your day and
try one out next time you're feeling
stressed it can really make your anxiety
feel less all-consuming
once you connect with your body and turn
the volume down on your anxiety two
important things will happen
first when that email comes in you'll be
in a better position to evaluate what
about it makes you anxious is it that
you've taken on too much or that you
feel insecure about a particular skill
set in other words you'll be able to use
this emotion anxiety for exactly what it
was evolved to do
warn you about potential dangers so you
can become aware of them and find ways
to effectively and creatively address
them in your everyday life
second once you find the warning signals
in your anxiety you'll be able to
communicate with others you might seek
out advice from a trusted colleague when
that difficult issue arises or you might
even have a conversation with your boss
about how to prioritize projects
because you're no longer in fight or
flight mode asking for that support
won't feel nearly as threatening
and one of the best gifts of approaching
your anxiety in this way is that you
will be able to notice those telltale
signs of anxiety in everyone else around
you especially those forms of anxiety
you're most familiar with and what will
that do
that will allow you to give that person
a smile or a kind word to help them
through that moment in other words your
own form of anxiety can boost your
personal superpower of empathy and I
can't think of anything we need in this
world today more than higher levels of
empathy for one another
your take home in all of this
if you breathe move and take note of
what your anxiety is signaling you'll
feel more fulfilled more creative more
connected and less stressed overall and
that's my wish for every one of us
[Music]